ya son nueve los ataques contra kiev
desde que comenzó el mes de mayo y todos
empiezan a tener una característica
similar Rusia Envía una serie de misiles
que en todos estos casos incluido esta
madrugada son interceptados por la
defensa antiaérea de Ucrania y es que
uno de los objetivos de esos ataques
según los analistas militares no
solamente es identificar las posiciones
de esas baterías de defensa que han sido
dadas por occidente en los últimos meses
sino también confundirlas esta mañana
volvían a interceptar esos misiles pero
también como ya es costumbre o
tristemente cuando esas proyectiles se
activan para interceptar esos misiles
las partes de ellos caen en algunas
sectores de la ciudad creando incendios
y algunos daños como sucedió esta
madrugada esta madrugada también se vio
otra característica de estos ataques y
es que después de los misiles vienen los
drones que buscan identificar eran las
posiciones de esta defensa antiaérea
según las fuerzas militares ucranianos
fueron 30 misiles los lanzados durante
la noche y la madrugada 29 de ellos
fueron interceptados y uno logró romper
esa Barrera en la ciudad de odesa donde
al menos una persona murió y dos
personas quedaron heridas esto sucede
cuando ya se fue de Ucrania el enviado
especial de China que buscaba encontrar
una sesión fuego una salida negociada a
esta guerra china recordemos Ese es tal
vez el país más cercano a Rusia en este
momento Y está en una campaña de buscar
una salida negociada a la guerra el
enviado especial dijo que no hay una
regla mágica para En estos casos que
ambas partes tienen que encontrar la
confianza para negociar y ahora sigue su
camino hacia otros países europeos y
Moscú donde seguirá luchando para buscar
una salida a esta guerra